[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Anne Gellinek
das amerikanische Repräsentantenhaus hat
also wieder einen Vorsitzenden nach vier
Tagen und 15 Abstimmungen hatte Kevin
McCarthy kurz nach Mitternacht endlich
seine Mehrheit zusammen zu feiern gibt
es allerdings nichts denn das Signal das
von diesem Machtkampf ausgeht ist dreist
der Erpressung funktioniert eine Gruppe
radikaler Blockierer aus der eigenen
republikanischen Partei hatte McCarthy
ein Zugeständnis nach dem anderen
abverlangt die Botschaft ist klar dieser
parlamentsvorsitzende ist einer auf
Abruf Benjamin Daniel berichtet aus
washing
es ist nicht schwer zu erraten welcher
DT Margery Taylor green gestern während
der Abstimmung anrief die Ultra Rechte
Abgeordnete brüstet sich heute sogar
damit dass Donald Trump über sie
Einfluss auf die Abstimmung nahm Kevin
McCarty im Schulterschluss mit den
Rechtsradikalen
nun darf der Sprecher von Trumps Gnaden
also doch den Hammer schwingen nach
chaotischen Tagen hat Kevin McCarty die
Stimmen zusammengekratzt nachdem die
Sekretärin des Repräsentantenhauses 14
Mal verkünden musste dass kein Sprecher
gewählt wurde hieß es nun spät in der
Nacht
ehrenwerte Kevin McCarthy aus
Kalifornien hat eine Mehrheit der
Stimmen erzielt und ist damit gewählter
Sprecher des Repräsentantenhauses
vor allem die Stimmen seiner härtesten
Gegner hat sich McCarthy teuer erkauft
unter anderem mit wichtigen
ausschussposten große Mitspracherecht
bei Gesetzesentwürfen und wohl auch mit
Zugeständnissen in Sachen Deckelungen
der Militärausgaben daher wirkten seine
Worte gestern für viele kaum glaubwürdig
als Sprecher des Hauses fühle ich mich
in erster Linie nicht gegenüber meiner
Partei verpflichtet meiner Fraktion oder
gar dem Kongress meine Verpflichtung
unsere Verpflichtung haben wir gegenüber
unserem Land
ein Land das seit dessen
Bürgerkriegszeit nicht mehr ein solch
unwürdiges kongressspektakel erlebt hat
dazu passend diese Szene von gestern
Abend als sich McCarthy von einem seiner
größten Widersacher mad Gates abwendet
versucht ein anderer Abgeordneter diesen
täglich anzugreifen eine symbolzene als
Vorbote für unruhige Zeiten
die Konsequenz wird nun sein dass diese
kleine Koalition die sich gegen McCarthy
gestellt hat enorme Macht haben wird er
hatte ohnehin schon eine sehr dünne
Mehrheit und jetzt werden die Regeln im
Repräsentantenhaus dahingehend angepasst
dass eine Handvoll Mitglieder für ihn
richtig große Probleme verursachen kann
und als würde er diesen Umstand gar
nicht begreifen blickt McCarthy voller
Vorfreude in die Zukunft
was wir hier heute machen oder in den
nächsten Wochen Monaten oder nächstes
Jahr wird ein Vorgeschmack geben auf das
was noch kommen wird
nach all dem was in den letzten Tagen
vorgefallen ist können viele diese
Aussage eigentlich nur als Drohungen
empfinden
und darüber wollen wir reden mit der
Außenpolitik Expertin Constanze
stelzen-müller in Washington guten Abend
guten Abend nochmals ist das überhaupt
ein Sieg den Kevin McCarty da errungen
hat oder befindet er sich jetzt nicht
vollständig in den Händen der radikalen
Republikaner
ich glaube das können wir heute noch
nicht sagen stand heute klar ist das
eher in den letzten drei Tagen
fürchterlich gedemütigt worden ist aber
er hat sein Ziel erreicht und er hat das
sollte man auch nicht vergessen wichtige
Verbündete unter den
also ich bin gleich zu sagen normalen
Republikanern und vor allen Dingen unter
dem minderheitensprecher im Senat Mitch
mcConnell der auf seiner Seite ist bei
den bei Kernthemen wie
Verteidigungsausgaben und Außenpolitik
insofern es kommt jetzt darauf an wie
sich diese Machtkämpfe konkret
ausspielen gucken wir noch einmal kurz
zurück auf diesen Wahlkrimi was waren
denn eigentlich oder was sind die Motive
der 20 Blockierer was treibt diese
radikalen Republikaner an
das ist eine wirklich gute Frage ob die
auch keine feste Antwort habe man kann
das so lesen dass dieses wenn Sie so
wollen die dritte Stufe eines versuchten
verfassungskurs ist am ersten am
sechsten Januar 2020 mit der Straße dann
hat man das in den Zwischenwahlen
versucht am 9.11 vergangenen Jahres die
er bekanntlich für die Republikaner weit
weniger gut ausgegangen sind als man
sich damals erhofft hatte und jetzt
glaube ich wird der Marsch über die
Institutionen versucht und worauf es
jetzt in den nächsten zwei Jahren bis
zur nächsten Präsidentenwahl
entscheidend ankommt ist ob es dieser
harten kleinen rechten gelingt die
republikanische Mehrheit zu dominieren
zu knechten so ein bisschen wie in der
russischen Revolution die deutsche wegen
die Menschen Wicken und vor allen Dingen
ob es ihnen gelingt die Regeln der
parlamentarischen Demokratie zu ändern
dann hätte Trump wohl die die Rolle von
Lenin welche Rolle hat denn Trump bei
dieser Wahl überhaupt gespielt
auch das ist hochgradig 2deutig er ist
hat offensichtlich immer noch enorm
Einfluss und ist ein
Stichwortgeber vielleicht sogar also
Befehlsgeber für die harte Rechte das
hat man ja gesehen in diesem schon
historischen Bild von dem Telefon das
machen die Taylor green einem
republikanischen an Abgeordneten hinhält
und sagt da jemand mit mir reden aber
auf dem Bild sieht man eben auch dass
der Abgeordnete das abwehrt und nicht
will andererseits hat sich Kevin Account
die nach dieser 15 Abstimmung öffentlich
bei Trump bedankt also ich sehe sowohl
Absetzbewegung als auch loyalitätsbeginn
Bekundung das wird einer der spannenden
Fragen der nächsten zwei Jahre werden
und was bedeutet jetzt dieser zumindest
im Moment im Moment von den radikalen
Republikanern dominierte Kongress für
Joe Biden für dessen weitere Regierung
also wir müssen noch sehen ob er
wirklich ob der Kongress wirklich von
den radikalen Republikanern dominiert
wird nochmal der Senat in dem die
Republikaner in der Minderheit sind
spielt auch eine sehr wichtige Rolle in
der Gesetzgebung und insbesondere in der
Gesetzgebung soweit sie
Verteidigungsausgaben und Außenpolitik
betrifft und da gibt es weitgehende
inhaltliche Einigkeit mit der
Administration was die Unterstützung der
Ukraine anbetrifft es wird mit
Sicherheit Untersuchungsausschüsse geben
versuche die Administration lahm zu
legen es wird also
Überprüfungen geben aber das
Verteidigungsbudget ist am Tag vor
Weihnachten noch verabschiedet worden
und die Waffenlieferungen und also hier
Verteidigungsbudget wir reden hier von
47 Milliarden Dollar für die Ukraine das
ist nicht nichts und die Waffenlieferung
an die Ukraine die Geschehen nicht etwa
aus Ankäufen von Waffen die dann
genehmigungspflichtig werden sondern die
werden aus Lagerbeständen genommen da
kann der Kongress also das Unterhaus
nicht so viel mitreden oder nicht
mitreden und insofern also vieles wird
sich hier an den Einzelheiten abspielen
in den nächsten Monaten wir es ist
erkennbar dass die harte Rechte stören
will es ist erkennbar dass die harte
Rechte die Verfassungsordnung als solche
mit Füßen tritt aber ob sie es Ihnen ein
wirklich ein Durchbruch gelingt in
diesen zwei Jahren ist noch eine völlig
offene Frage das heißt sie sind relativ
optimistisch dass die amerikanische
Vorreiterrolle bei der Unterstützung der
Ukraine erstmal so bestehen bleibt und
Europa nicht jetzt allein zu Hause
nein du hast ja also optimistisch würde
ich das nicht nennen aber ich habe ich
glaube wir können davon ausgehen dass
der Präsident im Verbund mit einem Senat
wo auch die republikanische Minderheit
im Wesentlichen auf seiner Seite ist
sehr weitgehende Befugnisse hat wo dann
die republikanische Mehrheit im Kongress
nicht wirklich stören kann die kann
anderweitig stören aber in der
Außenpolitik in der Unterstützung der
Ukraine und Europas erstmal nicht ganz
nicht nicht so wie man sich das
vielleicht erstmal vorgestellt hat aber
die
bis zum gewissen gerade werden sich wird
sich die harte Rechte jetzt in der
parlamentarischen Arbeit natürlich auch
entblößen und wir haben ja gesehen was
in konservativen harten rechten Parteien
in Europa das bedeutet hat wenn wenn sie
im Parlament plötzlich für die gesamte
Nation sichtbar werden das hat auch hier
und da zum Machtverlust geführt aber
trotzdem liegt in dieser in den
irrsinnigen Szenen der vergangenen Tage
auch eine Lehre für die konservativen
Parteien in Europa
die harte Rechte die antipal
anti-demokratische harte Rechte meint es
ernst und es wird dann ernst für die
Demokratie wenn die anfangen die Regeln
zu ändern
auch eine Lehre für für Europa unsichere
Aussichten in der amerikanischen
Innenpolitik vielen Dank Konstanze
Stelzen Müller war das von der Brookings
Institution in Washington herzlichen
Dank dorthin
schön seit einer knappen Stunde ist die
weihnachtswaffen Ruhe die russlands
Präsident Putin einseitig ausgerufen
hatte vorbei den Namen hatte sie wohl eh
nicht verdient die Realität ist das
russische Geschosse erneut bachmut und
andere ukrainische Positionen getroffen
haben sagte Präsident selenski in seiner
abendlichen Videobotschaft unterdessen
feierten die Spitzen von Kirche und
Staat in Russland das orthodoxe
Weihnachtsfest Material gilt als einer
der wichtigsten Unterstützer Putins und
seines Kriegs in der Ukraine weil dieser
den westlichen Einfluss auf orthodoxe
Christen zurückdränge über ein
Weihnachten so ganz ohne
Friedensbotschaft berichtet für Bedarf
aus Moskau
der Kreml Herr in weihnachtlicher
Isolation anders als in früheren Jahren
verlässt Wladimir Putin das Gelände
seines Amtssitzes nicht feiert den
Gottesdienst ganz allein in einer der
kreml-kathedralen in einer großbotschaft
schriftlich nicht etwa persönlich
übermittelt dankt er der Kirche für die
Unterstützung seiner sogenannten
spezialoperation
[Musik]
Frieden und Versöhnung mögen anderswo im
Mittelpunkt von Weihnachtsgottesdiensten
stehen in Moskau gießt das Oberhaupt der
russisch-orthodoxen Kirche noch Öl ins
Feuer
Patriarch Kirill beschuldigt Kiew die
orthodoxe Kirche in der Ukraine
zerstören zu wollen
wir glauben dass all diese teuflischen
Versuchungen nachlassen werden und
irgendwann nach einiger Zeit werden sich
viele mit Ironie oder einem müden
Lächeln an diese erbärmlichen Versuche
erinnern die traditionelle orthodoxe
Kirche in der Ukraine zur ruinieren
nicht erst seit Russlands Einmarsch ins
Nachbarland gilt der Patriarch als einer
der engsten Vertrauten putis die Männer
teilen die auch Fassung das Ukrainer und
Russen ein Volk sein wenn Putin jetzt
Satanismus im Westen wittert oder den
brutalen kämpfen ein moralisches Gewand
verpassen möchte gibt Kyrill im
Rückendeckung und je länger der
Militäreinsatz dauert je mehr russische
Opfer erfordert umso häufiger bemüht der
Präsident religiöse Rhetorik wie in
seiner Neujahrsansprache
der Schutz des Vaterlandes ist unsere
heilige Pflicht unseren Vorfahren und
unseren Nachkommen gegenüber die
moralische historische Wahrheit ist auf
unserer Seite
Staat und Kirche Militär und Religion in
Russland sind sie enge Verbündete
während der Verteidigungsminister über
die Rüstungsindustrie referiert lauscht
Kirill im Publikum
Großbritannien Kanada und Litauen haben
ihn mit Sanktionen belegt in Moskau
folgen viele den Erzählungen von
patriarch-
geht leider nicht den richtigen Weg und
vertritt mehr die westlichen Interessen
das ist aber nicht im Interesse des
ukrainischen Volkes oder des russischen
Volkes alle Nazis müssen die Waffen
niederlegen und alle Nazis müssen
festgenommen werden dies ist unsere
Meinung nicht nur meine viele denken so
ich unterstütze unseren Präsidenten und
seine Entscheidungen
davon eine Botschaft des Friedens zu
senden ist Moskau weit entfernt nicht
nur in dieser Weihnachtsnacht
und jetzt macht Heinz weiter mit
Nachrichten und die beginnen in Iran die
EU hat mit Entsetzen auf die
Hinrichtungen zweier Demonstranten
zweier weiterer Demonstranten in Iran
reagiert
bundesaußenministerin baerburg sprach
sich dafür aus den Druck der EU
gegenüber Iran zu erhöhen im iranischen
Staatsfernsehen wurde der Tod der beiden
Männer vermeldet dazu wurden Bilder der
Justizbehörden mit dem angeblichen
Geständnis in der Verurteilten gezeigt
ihnen wird vom Regime zur Last gelegt
für den Tod eines Mitglieds der
Revolutionsgarden während der Proteste
verantwortlich zu sein
das Auswärtige Amt rät von nicht
notwendigen Reisen nach China ab zur
Begründung wird auf den hohen Stand an
corona-infektionen verwiesen dass
chinesische Gesundheitssystem sei
überlastet auch die ausreichende
Versorgung in medizinischen Notfällen
seit davon betroffen
auf Hawaii ist der Vulkan killeroya
wieder ausgebrochen die spektakulären
Eruptionen ereignen sich bisher
ausschließlich im Inneren des Kraters
der weit ab von bewohnten Gebieten liegt
der 1250 Meter hohe Vulkan ist der
Mittelpunkt eines Nationalparks auf der
Hauptinsel Hawaii er gilt als einer der
aktivsten Vulkane der Welt
eine Meldung vom Sport
langlauf-olympiasiegerin Katharina
Hennig hat die vorletzte Etappe der Tour
de Ski in balde femme gewonnen die
26-Jährige holte damit in diesem
Massenstart Rennen über 15 km in der
klassischen Technik den ersten Weltcup
sie ihrer Karriere wenn ich ging auf der
Zielgeraden an ihren Konkurrentinnen
vorbei die in der Gesamtwertung führende
Schwedin Karlsson wurde Zweite
und jetzt die Lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 10 11 18 20 26 40 Superzahl 2 und
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
556 und noch die Wetteraussichten morgen
in einem Streifen vom Oberrhein bis zur
Oder überwiegen die Wolken und es regnet
zeitweise sonst bleibt es meist trocken
und die Sonne kann auch mal scheinen die
Temperatur steigt auf Werte von drei bis
zwölf Grad in den nächsten Tagen gibt es
oft Regen am Montag und Dienstag
oberhalb von 800 Metern auch Schnee nach
einer kleinen Abkühlung zum Wochenstart
steigt die Temperatur am Mittwoch wieder
bis 13 Grad
das war es von uns an diesem
Samstagmorgen sind wir zu gewohnter Zeit
um 21 Uhr 45 für Sie da schönen Abend
und tschüss
[Musik]